il est important de comprendre d'où
vient ce virus
le virus de lakovic 19 pourrait-il
provenir d'un laboratoire
même si vous croyez que les chances que
ce soit une fille de son d'un pour cent
on doit quand même enquêté première
partie du loch est troublante sur les
origines des virus qui a bouleversé la
planète
personne ne veut être coupable de
décisions qui ont peut-être entraîné des
millions de morts non identifiés
bienvenue à découverte
[Musique]
le ver sera skov 2 qui a causé la
pandémie pourrait provenir d'un
laboratoire au
tout début cette hypothèse était farfelu
complotistes
un an et demi plus tard le ton a changé
l'hypothèse est devenu plausible lab
accident peu commun commun c'est
l'histoire que nous vous raconterons au
cours des deux prochaines semaines
celles d'internautes qui dans l'ombre
ont investigué la question et des
scientifiques qui ont mis en péril leur
carrière pour mettre jour des
informations troublantes
nous ne savons pas ce qu'ils ont dans
leur collection parce que toutes leurs
bases de données a été mise hors ligne
l'hypothèse est effrayante si elles
s'avèrent les répercussions cet immense
personne ne veut être coupable de
décisions ayant pu causer des millions
tard
il inquiète scientifiques complexes
brouillé par les intérêts politiques de
géant
certains pays essaient d'en faire un
enjeu politique cela ne veulent pas
connaître l'origine du
sspt que le ms leur demande voulez vous
vraiment connaître l'origine ou jouer à
faire de la politique
après un an l'enquète sur les origines
l'aco vide des voix le peu de contrôle
que nous avons sur les expériences
risquée menée sur les pathogènes les
plus dangereux de la planète du sport
[Musique]
elle projette le spectre d'un futur
possible une prochaine pandémie causée
par des virus créé par l'humain
l' enquête commence ici dans la ville de
wuhan en chine centrale
omar chirwan al
plus de 600 et al dix mille visiteurs
par jour côtoyant des animaux vivants
sauvage issus de commerce illégaux
selon les autorités chinoises les
premiers cas sont liés à ce marché c'est
pour cela que dès le départ pour
beaucoup il est évident que c'est ici
que le virus se seraient transmis pour
la première fois d'un animal un humain
c'est l'avis du virologiste robert gary
la nouvelle orléans il est un expert des
maladies émergentes
il fait partie des premiers à examiner
les séquences génétiques du strass cov
de
ce commerce d'animaux sauvages est
certainement la source du premier strass
et c'est la source la plus probable du
strass cov 2
mai dès janvier 2020 sur les réseaux
sociaux circulent une autre hypothèse
celle d'une fuite de laboratoire
à une dizaine de kilomètres du marché se
trouve l'institut de virologie de ou
anne un complexe composé de plus d'une
vingtaine de laboratoires répartis sur
deux sites
cet institut est l'épicentre mondial de
la recherche sur les coronavirus tu
souris
en particulier depuis la pandémie de
sera sans 2003 apparue en chine qui
avait mis toute la planète sur le qui
vive elle a révélé le risque posé par
les coronavirus
depuis la mission de l'institut étudié
les coronavirus pour prévenir une
prochaine pandémie
dès janvier robert gary se penche sur la
séquence génétique du virus avec
d'autres virologue de renault notre
première impression était que son
origine pouvait provenir de l'une ou
l'autre des hypothèses
mais à force d'accumuler des données et
d'examiner le virus nous sommes arrivés
à la conclusion que ce virus n'était
certainement pas bricoler en laboratoire
que son origine la plus probable est
naturel -
le 17 mars 2020 avec ses collègues il
publie une lettre dans le journal nature
medicine en deux paragraphes il écarte
l'hypothèse d'une fuite de laboratoire
leur correspondance suit une autre
lettre influente parue dans la revue des
lands est signée par 27 scientifique ils
écrivent le nous unissons pour condamner
les théories complotistes suggérant que
le virus n'aurait pas une origine
naturelle
à ce moment là leur argument semble
solide le strass cov 2 est trop
différent de tout virus répertoriés il
n'observe aucun signe visible de
manipulation sur la séquence génétique
du virus et les épidémies passé sont
d'origine animale ces deux lettres font
autorité
aux yeux du public et de nombreux
scientifiques il ya consensus des
experts
mais pas pour ali natcan une post
doctorante en thérapie génique au bond
institute affiliés au et matis et à
harvard pour elle ces lettres ont
l'effet contraire
cet article a été l'un des premiers
éléments qui m'a fait prendre très au
sérieux l'hypothèse d'une fuite du
laboratoire
au prat en 2020 elle émerge comme une
des rares voix scientifiques sur twitter
a discuté publiquement la possibilité
d'une fuite de laboratoire elle souligne
les faiblesses de ses lettres
il semble avoir évalué des scénarios
très spécifique de fuite de la bo
impliquant de l'ingénierie génétique
mais ils n'ont pas envisager des
scénarios plausibles de fuite plus
raisonnable
c'est que depuis des années les
chercheurs de l'institut de virologie de
wuhan échantillonne les endroits reculés
de la chine à la recherche des prochains
pathogènes susceptibles de causer une
pandémie les forceront
cette vidéo promotionnelle donne un
aperçu de leur travail dans des grottes
infesté de chauves souris
[Musique]
il rampait sur le ventre dans des
grottes de choses serait difficile
d'accès au fil des ans ils ont collecté
des dizaines de milliers d'échantillons
provenant d'animaux et même du main
cherchant spécifiquement ces coronavirus
ces pathogènes humain ils ont ainsi
ramené à one plus de 22 mille
échantillons créant une des plus
importantes collections de corona virus
de type strass au monde
dans leur laboratoire à roanne les
chercheurs mène de vastes programmes de
recherche pour étudier ces pathogènes
il y a donc un risque que l'un d'eux a
été infectée sur le terrain dans les
grottes ou en échantillonnant des
personnes vivant près de chez
nous alors ils ont rapporté ces
échantillons au laboratoire et on puce
infectée accidentellement les étudiants
ou en les cultivant
un autre élément alimente ses doutes
depuis le début de la coved 19 on nous a
dit qu'il portait toujours des
équipements de protection complet
mais plusieurs articles et reportages
passé sur l'institut de virologie
montrent le contraire
ils ont même trouvé des photos du
personnel de l'institut son gant au mas
en train de manipuler des chauves-souris
matt
ali vers 2020 la voie de la pause
doctorante ali natcan ne fait pas le
poids contre la liste imposante de
scientifiques de renom qui rejette
l'hypothèse d'une fuite de laboratoire
et surtout contre la crédibilité de
cheese only chercheuse à l'institut de
virologie de wuhan
elle est à la tête de ses travaux sur
les coronavirus de chauves souris si une
des plus grands experts mondial de
strass
maintenant
elle est surnommée la batterie sommes
en février 2020 alors qu'elle est au
coeur de la controverse elle écrit sur
le réseau social web os je jure sur ma
vie que ceci n'a rien à voir avec mon
laboratoire
mais on découvrira plus tard dans une
rare entrevue accordée au synthétique
américaine qu'elle a eu des doutes
causés par une interrogation capitale
la voici tous s'entendent pour dire que
l'ancêtre du sras scop deux premiers
sans doute la chauve souris tout comme
ses proches parents connus il aurait
probablement pour hôtes naturels la
chauve-souris rhinolophe or l'air de
répartition de cette chauve-souris se
situe à plus de 1600 km 2 ou ap
alors comment ce virus at-il voyagé
depuis cet habitat jusqu'à où anne et où
s'est-il transmis à l'humain oui nous ne
savons pas comment le virus est passé de
sa version ancestrale dans la chauve
souris awan en 2019 ce parcours est un
mystère complet
la première réaction de shiso ni est
rapportée ici je n'aurais jamais pensé
que ce genre de choses pourraient
survenir à one en chine centrale la
chercheuse en et si surprise qu'elle
croit que les autorités ont dû se
tromper que ça ne peut pas être un corps
en un virus
gisenyi et d'autre on échantillonnés des
chauves souris dans toute la chine et
des milliers dans la province de roanne
ils n'y ont jamais trouvé de virus de
type strass ils se sont même servis de
la population de la province de one
comme groupe témoin négatif démontrant
que ces personnes n'étaient pas
couramment exposés aux strass alors pour
eux c'était une surprise
chilly envisage immédiatement une fuite
de laboratoire et rapportent en avoir
perdu le sommeil ce n'est qu'après avoir
fouillé dans ses données qu'elle aurait
été rassuré
bref ce qui différencie les deux
hypothèses celle aux intermédiaires
selon l'hypothèse d'une origine
naturelle comme dans les épidémies passé
le virus aurait transité depuis la
chauve souris par un animal plus
semblable biologiquement à l'humeur il
se serait alors rendu à one par la
traite des animaux vendus au marché
selon l'hypothèse de la fugue de
laboratoire ils se seraient transmises
sur les sites d'échantillonnage
directement de la chauve souris à
l'humain ou par des échantillons ramenés
à one même si vous croyez que les
chances que ce soit une fuite sont de 1
% on doit quand même enquêté lorsque
cette pandémie est devenue si importante
que le public mérite de savoir comment
elle a commencé afin de prévenir une
future pandémie
[Musique]
les interrogations dali natcan sont mal
reçus et sa réputation est mise à mal
je pense qu'à l'époque j'étais naïve
quand j'ai lu cet article j'ai cru que
c'était une invitation aux scientifiques
à commenter et à répondre
j'avais tort et je m'en rends compte
ce n'était pas une invitation
mais une affirmation d'éminents
scientifiques qu'aucun scénario de fuite
de la boue mais plausible
mais ali natcan persiste et ses soupçons
ne feront que croître avec l'apport
d'internautes intrigués par les
multiples contradictions de l'institut
de virologie de wuhan
après la pause le manque de transparence
à l'ère des internautes mais aussi des
scientifiques
au printemps 2020 les hypothèses les
plus farfelues sur les origines lakovic
fusent
sur son compte twitter harry natcan
départage méthodiquement le déluge
d'informations celle plausible de sel
sans fondement
ces publications attire des internautes
déterminée a exploré l'hypothèse d'une
fuite de laboratoire
une vingtaine d'entre eux se regroupent
sous le nom de drastiques
beaucoup sont anonymes certains
irrévérencieux mais on y retrouve aussi
des scientifiques biologistes
immunologiste
et l'ingénieur francisco d assises d
ribera un analyste de données à madrid
ils ne vont pas d'à priori on n'a donc
pas peur de ce qu'on trouve
ce qui réunit d'abord drastique c'est
ceci une publication de chizy de
l'institut de virologie de wuhan en
février 2020 elle y analyse le nouveau
virus sras skov
2010 annonce aussi que son laboratoire a
en sa possession un autre coronavirus el
atter g13 le plus proche cousin connu du
strass cov 2 à 96,2 % identique
une révélation dérangeante pour
drastiques ce qui les intrigue c'est le
peu de détails fournis sur la provenance
de ce nouveau virus
alors nous avons commencé à échanger
nous des coupes et nos opinions et nous
donne et
se joint à eux la microbiologiste
rossana segreto alors à l'université
d'innsbruck en autriche je suis devenu
très très curieuse à propos de cet
échantillon je vais entrer dans schengen
une base de données où vous pouvez le
comparer avec tous les virus
elle découvre que ce virus est déjà
répertoriés dans une base de données
mais sous un autre nom ils auraient été
prélevés dans la région du mondial dans
le sud de la chine à huile ou perdait
toujours le nom d'un échantillon vous
pouvez le modifier dans votre
laboratoire mais ensuite quand vous
publiez une recherche vous référez
toujours à vos articles passés c'est
vraiment étrange qu'il ne mentionnait
pas leur propre travail
les morceaux du casse-tête prennent
forme grâce à un autre membre de six
coeurs elle jeune indien de 30 ans
aventure a commencé avec un mot clé les
caractères chinois pour mondiale
j'ai donc commencé sur google dans
toutes les bases de données en
commençant par les revues universitaires
il plonge dans une des bases de données
de publications académiques les plus
importantes de chine
ils y découvrent deux thèses supervisés
par des chercheurs chinois de renom et
que je les ai publiées
les gens ont commencé à les traduire
sa découverte confirme les soupçons de
drastique est ratée g13 a bien été
prélevés dans la région du monde jane
dans une mine où est survenu un incident
grave en 2012
[Applaudissements]
six mineurs y comptera qu'une forme
inconnue de pneumonie trois ans meurt
une des thèses décrit en détail les
symptômes et le traitement avec
radiographies à l'appui forte fièvre
toux douleurs corporelles difficultés à
respirer des symptômes similaires à la
cause id comme le confirmera plus tard
plusieurs scientifiques
c'était la première fois que l'incident
était directement lié à l'institut de
virologie
en mars 6 ml en entrevue confirme avoir
échantillonnés cette mine après
l'éclosion nelly affirme que la maladie
était causée par un champignon
en fait la thèse de maîtrise contredit
ce propos
quatre démineurs porte des anticorps
spécifiques un virus de type strass le
plus éminent spécialiste du strass a été
invité à soigner l'un des patients le
docteur angel
célèbre pneumologue chinois il est le
premier à avoir décrit le virus du
strass et son diagnostic était que ces
décès avait été causée principalement
par une infection virale un diagnostic
d'une grande importance scientifique
ce serait alors une première observation
d'une transmission directe de la chauve
souris à l'humain
une découverte qui a dû secouer les
scientifiques dans un pays marqué par le
premier strass
l'incident a dû sonner l'alarmé car au
moins trois laboratoires ont été
impliqués dans l'échantillonnage de la
mine le laboratoire du cdc le
laboratoire de l'institut de virologie
de one et des chercheurs de pékin
drastique est convaincu d'avoir fait des
découvertes explosives
je m'attendais à ce que cela fasse les
manchettes c'était une découverte
majeure j'ai dû envoyer des courriels à
plus d'une centaine de journalistes de
la plupart des médias occidentaux
[Musique]
je n'ai reçu aucune réponse
francisco des assisses poursuit il
plonge dans toutes les publications et
présentation de shenley il tient des
tableaux où il compile tous les vélos
sera portée y croiser des bases de
données il déduit qu'en plus de ra tg
13,8 autre souche de virus de type
strass ont été prélevés dans la mine du
mondial
gp une sorte d'énorme sudoku et j'étais
assez convaincus que ces virus provenant
de la mine
drastique questions à répétition
l'éditeur de nature qui a publié chez
nle ça a été très long nous avons
martelé nos questions sur twitter et par
courriel beaucoup de gens voulaient que
ce soit clarifiée
finalement le 17 novembre 2020 j'use
inglee publié un addendum à son article
2 février elle confirme les soupçons de
drastique entre 2012 et 2015 son équipe
est retourné deux fois par année à la
mine du mondial près de vingt mille 3
122 échantillons dont est ratée g13 et
huit autres virus apparentés dans la
copie 19 à émerger l'institut de
virologie avait en sa possession neuf
des plus proches arrondi virus ils ont
choisi de dévoiler au monde que l'un
d'entre eux le plus proche
le problème c'est qu'ils ne nous ont pas
parlé de cette mine jusqu'à ce que
drastique la découvre ils ne nous ont
pas parlé de ses huit autres virus de
type strass donc toutes ces parties
vraiment importante de l'histoire de ces
virus étroitement lié aux strass deux
ont dû être retirés de force du labo de
one par ses internautes détective
oui je crois que ce qu'elle a fait est
parfaitement normal elle publie un
article dans le magazine nature c'est
probablement le meilleur journal au
monde pour ce type de recherche et donc
elle a eu trois mille mots pour décrire
ce nouveau virus c'est ce que vous avez
quand vous écrivez un article dans
nature ce n'est pas beaucoup de monde
ce n'est pas normal parce que partager
ces infos au début de la pandémie peut
sauver des vies vous pouvez dire que ce
virus doit être prise au sérieux car ses
plus proches parents ont été trouvés
dans une mine au la moitié des personnes
qui sont tombées malades sont mortes
tout cela ne prouve en rien qu'il y
avait une fuite de laboratoire mais
témoigne d'une absence de transparence
nous avons demandé de la transparence à
l'institut mais ils ne veulent pas
partager l'accès à leur liste
d'échantillons ou leur séquence alors
oui nous avons des raisons d'avoir des
doutes nous avons posé des questions et
nous attendons toujours des réponses
et cette absence de transparence est
encore plus troublante au su des
expériences contreversé mené depuis des
années à l'institut de virologie de
wuhan qui inquiète un autre groupe de
scientifiques cette fois avec assez
d'autorité pour influencer le débat
[Musique]
après la pause modifié à virus pour
qu'ils puissent infecter les humains
[Musique]
de toutes les villes du monde la
pandémie a débuté à ou anne au lieu de
la recherche sur les coronavirus de type
sera ce
une coïncidence qui préoccupe aussi
d'autres scientifiques plus discret dès
le début de la pandémie
ou celle d'une communauté composée
d'experts en sécurité d'ex agents de
renseignement des personnes de la
défense et de l'armée
philippe allen sauce et experte en
menaces biologiques au king's college de
londres elle conseille régulièrement
l'onu sur ces questions
avec nous demandions en tant que groupe
y at il une dimension sécuritaire à
cette pandémie ce que nous envisagions
ce n'était pas des complots on se posait
des questions critiques
même interrogation de ce côté ci de
l'atlantique
la clé c'était hourra le biologiste
richard et bright envisage immédiatement
la fuite de laboratoire
toutes les personnes qui ont débattu de
ses sujets au cours des deux dernières
décennies ont immédiatement pensé que
c'était une possibilité qui ne pouvait
être écartée
karawan l'institut de virologie est
réputé depuis des années pour ses
expériences contreversé
une forme d'expérience qui soulève le
débat depuis 2000
en conséquence directe du 11 septembre
et des envois postaux d'anthrax
l'académie nationale des sciences a créé
un comité en charge d'examiner la
recherche biomédicale préoccupante dit à
double usage
la commission identifie sept types de
recherche qui pose un risque élevé
michel veunac cette activité sont connus
sous le nom des sept péchés capitaux de
filles
parmi ses péchés une technique jusqu
alors jamais employé le gain de fonction
elle consiste à prendre des virus et par
manipulation génétique augmenter leurs
fonctions créant ainsi de nouveaux virus
jamais vu en nature plus transmissible
ou plus mortelles par exemple de l'avis
général les activités à risque le plus
élevé était celle qui modifient l'espèce
cible si vous prenez un pathogène 1
capable d'infecter les humains le détail
où les cultures et que vous le modifier
pour lui permettre d' infecté les
humains le bétail ou les cultures vous
créez une nouvelle menace
pourtant c'est ce que feront deux
laboratoires dix ans plus tard tous deux
financés par les états unis ils
construisent un nouveau virus il est
dérivé du h5n1 virus aviaire qui lorsque
transmis à l'homme à un taux de
mortalité de 60 % ils le rendent capable
d'infecter des mammifères par voie
respiratoire
c'était du gain de fonction avec le
niveau de menace le plus élevé
selon ceux qui mènent ces travaux le but
est de prévenir la prochaine pandémie
c'est new york on peut prédire la
prochaine pandémie de la grippe c'était
la fantaisie nous ne pouvons pas il ya
des articles ou en a a bien cru j'étais
là et que c'était mission impossible
inquiété par cette recherche simon wayne
hopson codécouvreur du vih est un des
premiers à alerter la communauté
scientifique se pose on y viennent fuite
personnes soit capable de projeter dans
l'avenir et prédire leur trajectoire
même si le risque est faible les
conséquences peuvent être gigantesque
richard et bright cocquerez le cambridge
working group plus de 300 scientifiques
qui réclame une supervision
gouvernementale du gan fonction
l'art actions aboutissent en 2014 le
gouvernement obama ordonne à moratoire
sur les expériences de gan fonctions
considérées préoccupante
l'idée c'est de donner à la communauté
scientifique
l'occasion de déterminer si ce type de
recherche à haut risque devaient se
poursuivre ici oui comment mieux le
réglementer et assurer une surveillance
malgré la contreverse malgré le
moratoire en 2015 ralph barriques un
chercheur américain en collaboration
avec cheese à gulli de l'institut de
virologie de wuhan présentent leurs
propres créations ces travaux sont alors
menées en caroline du nord à
châteaubriant
dans leur projet ils ont construit de
nouvelles coronavirus chimère ils ont
pris le gène de spicules d'un koroma
virus de type strass jamais caractérisée
et l'ont inséré dans un squelette du
premier sera sans nous ont montré que le
nouveau virus s'immerge pouvait infecter
des cellules humaines
c'est le spicules cette protéine externe
du virus qui détermine quelles espèces
le coronavirus est capable d'infecter en
modifiant le spéculent il est alors
possible de l'adapter aux cellules
humaines
ce travail publié en 2015 dans la revue
nature madsen a reçu beaucoup
d'attention des scientifiques des
spécialistes des politiques
c'est un des articles clés qui m'a
marqué ou les auteurs eux mêmes écrivent
plusieurs de notre communauté neyret que
ces recherches sont trop risquées mais
clairement il ne pensait pas que c'était
trop risqué puisque ensuite ils ont
poursuivi ses travaux
en 2017 chu young lee reprend cette
technique mais cette fois dans son
laboratoire à one elle utilise comme
charpente des virus de type sera prélevé
lors de ses missions dans des grottes du
yunnan
c'est donc encore le même genre
d'expérience et dans ce cas plutôt que
de le faire une fois il en faut 8 froide
et sur les juifs fois ils ont réussi à
construire deux virus capable d'infecter
des cellules humaines
cette publication n'est en fait que la
première étape d'un projet plus vaste
ces recherches sont financées encore une
fois par les états unis via un
intermédiaire et cohortes lines un
organisme dont la mission est de se
préparer à la prochaine pandémie il est
présidé par peter d'azac un spécialiste
en maladies transmises par les animaux
il connaît
les voici en entrevue en décembre 2019
peu avant la pandémie
[Musique]
sa vision est audacieuse employés le gan
fonctions afin de développer des vaccins
ou des médicaments avant même
l'apparition de la prochaine pandémie
et l'institut de virologie de one est au
coeur de ce plan montre
aucune publication du détail les
expériences menées à wuhan après
l'article de 2017 pour comprendre ce qui
s'y passe il faut donc suivre la trace
des demandes de subventions celle
déposée en 2018 sont révélatrices
la demande de subvention propose de
poursuivre et d'étendre le programme de
construction de coronavirus shimell et
la proposition était de le faire à
grande échelle en profitant du grand
nombre de nouveaux gènes véhicule
découvert grâce au projet
d'échantillonnage murray par le labo de
gwan
il emploie différents virus comme
charpente et inserts systématiquement
différence véhicule l'objectif
identifier combien et quelles mutations
sont nécessaires avant que ses livres
chimères ne soit capable d'infecter les
cellules humaines
et ses travaux ont porté fruit on
l'apprend en novembre 2019 sur twitter
alors qu'un chercheurs contestent
l'utilité de ces recherches peter d'azac
rétorquent qu'ils ont identifié plus de
50 nouvelles souches capables de se lier
aux cellules humaines en employant des
virus recombinant ces virus chimère
est-ce que l'institut de virologie
aurait pu assembler des chimères à
partir de virus prélevés dans la mine du
mondial là même où ont été trouvés est
ratée g13 le plus proche parent connu du
strass cov 2 ainsi que huit autres virus
apparentés
nous n'avons pas cette information
mais tous chercheurs qui s'intéressent
au potentiel pandémique qui plie
coronavirus de type strass prioriserait
très certainement les coronavirus qui
proviennent d'une mine au des individus
ont contracté une pneumonie de type
strass puis en sont morts
ces virus sont assurément ce que vous
privilégiez comme source de nouveaux
gènes de spicules ce serait aussi les
virus que l'on privilégierait comme
nouveau se connaître pour y introduire
des gènes de spicules d'autres
coronavirus
est ce que de telles expériences aurait
pu donner naissance ou sera skov 2
la réponse se trouve probablement dans
les ordinateurs de l'institut de
virologie
l'institut disposait d'une base de
données recensant les virus qu'ils
avaient en leur possession
mais un allié de drastiques découvre que
la base de données a été mise hors ligne
comme on peut le voir ici le 12
septembre 2019 deux mois avant la
pandémie
le fait que cette immense base de
données contenant plus de 22 mille
échantillons prélevés sur des animaux
sauvages ont disparu
et que personne n'en a fourni une copie
depuis l'émergence de la colle et 19 et
bien c'est choquant
questionné à ce sujet l'institut de
virologie se défend en répondant qu'elle
avait mise hors ligne suite à des cyber
attaques des stars il ya des choses que
nous ne savons pas et sur les tel
institut de one n'a pas été transparent
il nous ne connaissons pas toutes les
recherches qui ont été menées nous
connaissons pas tous les virus qu'ils
ont dans leur base de données
malgré la présence d'une des plus
importantes collections de corona virus
de type sras saumon en plein coeur de
howald
malgré la présence du virus est ratée
g13 le plus proche parent connu du
strass cov 2
malgré les découvertes de drastiques
malgré les expériences de gan fonction
qui suscite inquiétude depuis deux
décennies
malgré l'absence de transparence de
l'institut l'hypothèse d'une fuite de
laboratoire n'est pas prise au sérieux
elle est même ridiculisé ce qui m'a
vraiment persuadé de discuter de cette
hypothèse c'est que personne ne la
mettait sur la table
pourquoi
follow the money comme disent les
américains
il faut suivre la piste de l'argent
[Musique]
après la peau ce principal bailleur de
fonds de ces recherches controversé les
états unis
[Musique]
au printemps 2020 le président des états
unis donald trump accuse l'institut de
virologie de wuhan d'être à l'origine du
virus
ces supporters se range derrière lui le
débat se politise à quel point le
gouvernement américain était il vraiment
préoccupés par la possibilité d'une
fuite de laboratoire on a appris que
récemment par une enquête journalistique
dans la revue vanity fair
les services de renseignement ont
déclaré à plusieurs reprises examiner
les deux options c'était en mars avril
mai ses propos étaient si étroitement
lié aux théories du complot à l'époque
qu'il était difficile pour beaucoup de
les prendre au sérieux
on ne connaît que trois laboratoires
dans le monde qui mène ce genre
d'expérience de gan fonction sur les
coronavirus de type strass en caroline
du nord à châteaubriant au laboratoire
de ralph barriques à l'université du
texas mais le coc brunch à galveston et
à l'institut de virologie de wuhan en
chine tous financés par le gouvernement
américain les etats unis ont été le
principal bailleur de fonds de ce type
de recherche dans le monde plus
précisément le match et en particulier
l'institut national des allergies et des
maladies infectieuses
à la tête de cet institut le docteur
anthony facci deux minutes et lui même
qui pendant la pandémie sera la figure
de proue de la guerre américaine contre
lacko vide le directeur de l'institut
national des allergies et des maladies
infectieuses a été le plus ardent
défenseur de ce type de recherche à
chaque étape il a été celui qui a permis
élargi encourager et excusé ce type de
recherche
pendant plus d'une décennie anthony
faraci à subventionner et défendu les
recherches sur le gain de fonction
il écrit dans cette lettre d'opinion que
c'est un risque qui en vaut la peine et
dès janvier le docteur facci est alerté
par la possibilité d'une fuite de
laboratoire par robert gary et ses
collègues virologue
nous vous en parlions plus tôt ils sont
les auteurs de cette lettre dans nature
medicine qui a fait autorité dès le
début de la pandémie écartant de façon
décisive la possibilité d'une fuite de
laboratoire mais quelques semaines à
peine avant la publication la lettre
leur opinion était très différente oslo
- la fuite et est certainement l'une des
possibilités auxquelles nous avons pensé
lorsque nous faisons des découvertes
importantes
nous devons en informer les personnes
qui soutiennent notre recherche comme le
docteur pham chi nous étions donc en
discussion avec le nhs au sujet
leur échange de courriels avec anthony
faraci rendues publiques récemment par
la loi d'accès à l'information dévoile à
quel point leurs doutes étaient
importants le 31 janvier 2020 par
courriel christiane dawson un collègue
de robert gary notent les
caractéristiques inhabituelles et veut
voir de plus près si ces virus sont
potentiellement construit en laboratoire
il note que cette caractéristique est
incompatible avec les attentes de la
théorie de l'évolution
ce qui les perturbe c'est ce qu'on
appelle un site de clivage de furie un
élément sur le speaker du virus qui
facilitent l'entrée dans les cellules
humaines
à marseille en france le virologue
etienne decroly repère aussi cette
caractéristique est un fait part à son
collègue bruno canard
la première réaction qu'on a eue quand
on a découvert ce site c'est en tout cas
une inquiétude certaine c'est le un t4
un disque est d'insérer ce site inquiète
car depuis des années les scientifiques
insère des sites de clivage de furie
pour faire du gain de fonction et rendre
des virus plus infectieux dans la
littérature scientifique on retrouve
toute une série de travaux de recherche
dans laquelle des chercheurs de
différents laboratoires dans le monde
compte insérer ce type de suite
justement pour essayer de comprendre le
rôle de de ces sites de protéolyse dans
la pathogenèse du virus de la vie et
d'un point de vue évolutif ce site est
inattentif les coronavirus dans la
famille du sartre n'avait pas de site de
clivage la farine sauf ceux qui ont
atterri ce numéro 2 tiana évident unique
alors qu'ils tiennent de creully rend
cette découverte publique le débat fait
rage chez les spécialistes
pour certains ce site aurait pu
apparaître de manière naturelle mais
pour d'autres sa présence est le signe
évident d'une manipulation de
laboratoire
pour les virologues français il est
incompréhensible que robert gary et ses
collègues aient pu trancher si
rapidement sur l'origine du virus est
publiée sitôt cette lettre qui écarte la
fuite de laboratoire on a été tout de
suite frappé évidemment par une
impression d'un parti pris qui était
pris
par les auteurs alors même que pour nous
la question était vraiment beaucoup plus
ouverte que ce que ça n'était indiquée
dans cet article de science
la découverte de ce site de furie en
tout cas suffisamment inquiété anthony
facci pour convoquer une réunion au
lendemain des courriels samedi 1er
février
et
l'article du vanity fair révélera
comment des membres du gouvernement
américain ont ensuite tenté d'étouffer
la conversation sur la fuite de
laboratoire refusant d'ouvrir la boîte
de pandore
tous les individus de toutes ces agences
de financement qui ont financé
l'institut de virologie de wuhan et bien
au moment où ces individus ont réalisé
le lien potentiel avec ce labo il avait
un très fort intérêt à nier ce lien
championnat personne ne doit être
coupable de décisions qui ont peut-être
entraîner du million mort
pour nous
en
mars 2021 le virologue robert redford
accordera une entrevue choc as yann l il
était le directeur du center for disease
control au début de la pandémie
de mongolie il y a
anthony facci se défendra d'avoir
banalisé l'hypothèse l'a fait de
laboratoire
ce qui est surprenant et qu'on a
découvert plus récemment c'est à quel
point ils ont envisagé cette hypothèse
et à quel point il y avait des conflits
internes au sein du gouvernement
américain sur la façon d'aborder la
question de l'origine du virus
en avril 2020 en pleine pandémie après
plus d'une décennie de financement la
haine et met abruptement fin à la
subvention des cobayes lines et craignez
que ce virus ne viennent de la recherche
sur le gain de fonction et personne ne
veut être à ce siège les russies
le gouvernement américain n'est pas
seule à être embarrassée par la thèse la
fuite de laboratoire
et qu il semble être aussi
revenons aux lettres qui ont fait
autorité au début de la pandémie
celle-ci publié dans des laines 7 qui
qualifie de comploter ce la théorie
d'une fuite de laboratoire regardons
l'impressionnante liste de 27
signataires on apprendra plus récemment
que parmi eux 26 ont des liens avec
l'institut de virologie
parmi eux cinq qui travaille pour eco
heinz et son président peter d'azac qui
a rédigé puis park estrella signature de
cette lettre pourtant les auteurs
écrivent nous nous déclarons aucun
conflit d'intérêts
trois femmes il y avait un intérêt de
certains membres de la communauté de
virologie pour s'assurer que cette
hypothèse ne soit pas une option
possible
de nombreux journalistes ont repris ces
propos inspiré des voix les plus
éminentes de la communauté scientifique
qui ont créé ce sentiment de oui il ya
un consensus scientifique autour de ce
sujet
un an après le début de la pandémie le 7
janvier 2021 au soir après de longs mois
de tergiversations internes le
département d'état des états unis
invitent les experts pour discuter des
éléments scientifiques qui soutiennent
une fuite de laboratoire parmi les 29
invités ralph barriques l'ancien
collaborateur de gisenyi et ali natcan
je ne connaissais personne dans la pièce
il devait y avoir des dizaines des
scientifiques iny nous sommes tous
entendu du moins selon ma perception
qu'il y avait trop peu de données pour
dire si c'était naturel ou dans la
bourre alors une vraie investigation
devait être mené
la conférence sera tenue confidentielle
tous les yeux sont alors tournés vers l'
enquête à venir de l'om s oui oh oui
tout 2000 insua veulent en tout 2000 ans
ou dave élite one love tonnes ou
interpelle
où
on vous
après la pause un rebondissement de
dernière heure
cette semaine une nouvelle vient
bouleverser la donne drastique viendra
en public une demande de subvention des
isles soumise à la défense américaine
dix huit mois avant le début de la
pandémie cette demande dévoile un projet
impliquant l'institut de virologie de
wuhan elle propose d'introduire sur des
coronavirus de type strass des sites de
clivage de furie
une découverte choc parce que cette
caractéristique génétique est aussi
présente sur le sera ce kof 2 elle
soulève les soupçons depuis un an car
pour plusieurs elle est un signe d'une
manipulation en laboratoire
pourtant ce projet dirigé par peter
d'azac n'a jamais été rendue publique
jusqu'à présent la défense américaine a
refusé cette demande mais d'autres l'ont
de celles financées on le sait pas
encore mais c'est une preuve écrite des
intentions de l'institut et une autre
coïncidence dérangeante
ne manquez pas la suite dimanche
prochain de la part de toute l'équipe
merci d'avoir été là bonsoir
[Musique]